Today is National Check the Register Day.
Um, so go to check the register dot,
I e, and make sure that you are still on the register.
I know for a fact that
even if you have been registered to vote in the past,
sometimes you're taken off it.
I'm not really sure why. Um,
so say it to your friends,
say it to your family to check and make sure you're on.
What is it, dirt on my ceiling?
Um, to make sure you're still honest.
Uh, we.
The local and European elections are coming up on June 7th,
and we desperately need people who will push people first,
who put housing, who put nature,
who put a sustainable future front and center to negotiations.
We can't really afford to keep going the way we're going.
The status quo is not really serving anybody.
It's making a lot of profit for a few people.
But for a better future, make sure you register to vote.
Check the register.